this week on quadriga World Cup risks
can Brazil win with just a month to go
until the world's biggest football
festival the scene on many of Brazil's
streets is one of anger and violence
protests have been triggered by concerns
that business alone will benefit from
the world cup while the poor are pushed
aside police crackdowns in the shanty
towns have left a number of people dead
or wounded in some cases the violence
has spread to tourist areas Brazil is a
nation of football lovers but the World
Cup has become a magnet for wider
criticisms of government and society so
we'll violence overshadow the
competition or will sport win the day
your host this week alyas lon hello and
welcome to quadriga the countdown to the
2014 World Cup in Brazil has begun and
soon 32 teams will battle for the
greatest prize in world football but
there's a cloud hanging a little bit
over the games as anti-government
protests have been staged in Brazil
leading many to wonder if they will
hamper and affect the world cup and
that's exactly what I want to talk about
on today show together with these three
experts welcome to da do Ottilie Nelly
is a journalist documentary filmmaker
and professor at the U Hannah's kaplan
university in Linz Austria he has
written and published extensively on
that in America Sven Goldman is a
reporter for the German newspaper dear
tagesspiegel he has been reporting
mainly on football and in that capacity
has been to Latin America and particular
Brazil many times Astrid panga de
Oliveira is an editor for the Brazilian
desk at Deutsche Welle previously she
was based in Rio de Janeiro where she
served as the Brazil correspondent for
the German newspaper Qatargas cycle
welcome to you all van Goldman before we
get to the protest let's talk about this
huge event billions of television
watchers will be glued to the TV set for
30 days to see if Spain will will be
done away if you will as the reigning
champion what do you think is the allure
the appeal to the World Cup everybody's
an expert you can split was spread
people all over the world everybody can
talk about the game everybody knows the
game and everybody knows best about the
game and that makes it so are fantastic
for everybody and the game let's compare
a little bit to the Olympics there's
always an unwritten rivalry if you will
they say the Olympics is the greatest
sporting event in the world many people
say forget that it's certainly the world
cup what's your take I think so too
because it is so easy the game is so
easy everybody understands that
everybody knows it everybody knows the
big the big stars and now everybody Rose
knows everybody is an expert that's it
so the excitement is building says slang
Goldman perhaps not so much in Linz
Austria Dario because the Austrians did
not qualify nonetheless you know that in
America very well what do these games
what does the World Cup mean to not only
Brazil but the region well obviously
like good football is the game for the
region even the countries that a few
years ago used to be more plane watching
and playing baseball are switching more
and more the football like Venezuela for
example or some other countries so it's
obviously a very important event but at
the same time as we can see it raises a
lot of criticism because of the business
behind it and because of all
implications for the people in the
region and isolated indeed the criticism
has been building ever since June when
Brazil hosted the Confederations Cup
what started out as a protest against
the rise in bus fare slowly
merged if you will into a much wider
movement as somebody who knows Brazil
very well did you see that coming I
think was a surprise for everybody that
thus the dimension of the protest the
whole movement was growing but now I
think the World Cup is kind of being
taken hostage by a lot of movements and
sectors of society he you know it's
suggested that he could solve a lot of
problems like they could solve the
problems of violins with a new police it
could solve the problems of economy with
creation of new jobs and investments
that could solve the problems of poverty
and so there's a huge over expectation
and this over expectation in my point of
view really causes a kind of frustration
because people realize that this worker
will not make a miracle and and
everybody is using it like a vehicle to
to reach some or another objective so
that's the mine opinion of the main
problem that you have a nova expectation
and certainly from the outside world
there's a little bit of if you will
surprise elements because we know
Brazilians are crazy about football
perhaps the country that is most
enthusiastic about the sports yet at the
same time 30 days away from the event
being staged in their own country the
differences or rather the issues that
are being talked about a very different
they're very different my my impression
is that everybody wants to have a piece
of the cake because they realize that
there is money for building stadiums but
suddenly they realize there's no money
to build hospitals or schools or maybe a
metro or a tram or urban Trump or
transport so people get angry that's
that's because they see the the division
of the money is not not serving not
serving them but serving FIFA serving
the world cup and they realize that it's
not their priorities
football but they don't love FIFA it's a
big difference it is a big difference
then and if we do look at the numbers
these are the most expensive World Cup
ever billions of dollars being spent as
has or bandits and on 12 new stadiums
some of them are not even done yet
that's true are excited to see what
happens in so called because the stadium
is not ready yet and it's going to see
the open game the opening game between
brazil and croatia I'm not sure what's
going to happen in man-hours I'm not
sure what's going to happen in Curitiba
and I think they'll be surprises and not
so nice surprises and Dario let's talk
about the money being spent here the
billions of dollars being spent acid was
saying the people in Brazil are are are
very exasperated about how this money is
being spent and where it's being spent
on there's no trickle-down effect here
is there the public is not benefiting
know it's there is no trickle-down
effect but the whole trickle-down effect
never existed in any of the ideas that
would be trickling down like this big
huge project same thing happens in South
Africa where the South African
government could earn only a twenty
percent of the money invested into the
games and and they thought it would be a
big business so and we have also the
problem like the corruption problem in
Brazil I mean when when they applied for
the World Cup the estimated like
spendings of 1.7 billion dollars now
it's about 14.7 billion dollars that
they're going to spend at least so that
shows what happens and at the same time
you have relations every few weeks like
three weeks ago Teixeira who used to be
the head of the Brazilian Football
Association and used to be a member of
the executive committee of the FIFA well
they found three hundred million dollars
on the account of his ten-year-old
daughter he cannot really explain where
it comes from it comes from the head of
Nike Brazil that you
to be the president of Barcelona so it's
not clear it might be part of the
accusations that the whole Katara World
Championship was bought by the different
Saudis it's very unclear but that upsets
people obviously and so that the whole
business is controlled by the FIFA that
there is no trickling down in fact at
all and that the promises that were
connected to Brazil I'm in Brazil had a
lot of improvements in investing in
education infrastructure during the last
10 years massively like they built 15
universities etc but the economic model
did not change at all and I think that
Brazil came to a crucial point where
this is now not longer accepted by
people i think could and should have the
money been used better on brazilian
infrastructure i think it's it's not all
know or not it's as he said already but
the brazilian government spent more
money in education and even the protest
last year and the confed cup they
contributed to to rise even more the
money which is being spent because all
the government changed law and the
exploit exploration of oil there's a big
part 75 percent which is being directed
to educational project which was decided
last year after the big demonstrations
so I think this is not the whole point
but i think it's it's very important to
see them the your the attitude towards
fifa because I think Brazil I think we
should be grateful to Brazil because
because it's the first country that
really challenged FIFA that a question
the almighty power of FIFA they're not
they're not willing to accept all the
reforms on the stadiums all the
obligation they're opposed to do and
it's the people that are questioning and
FIFA is getting mad about Brazil the
Secretary General said yes he has had
nightmares with Brazil because it's so
confusing and organization is not
working and I think that could be maybe
a star
the start of a discussion of the future
role of FIFA and World Cups and
organization I think it's it's kind of a
division that in Brazil is taking place
why do you think that this world cup
will re-examine how we look at FIFA do
you think that'll lead to reforms I
think we have to look at both sides of
course FIFA is a perfect villain we
don't have to talk about that and their
reasons for that but FIFA didn't ask for
12 stadiums they asked for nine stadiums
FIFA didn't ask for stadiums and
Brasilia where is no firstly team fifa
didn't ask for stadium in in cuiabá
where's know firstly team fifa didn't
ask for Sabean man hours in the jungle
where there's no football at all Brazil
want this world cup and Brazil wanted it
that way and I think first of all it's
Brazilian matter and if we look at it in
2007 when the decision was first
announced there was jubilation unanimous
jubilation on the part of Brazilians now
a recent survey has shown only fifty
percent of Brazilians now support the
games and are happy about the World Cup
being staged in their own country yeah I
think it had changed also the way we
look proposal in Germany or in Europe
Brazil's always beach Samba and football
Brazil is more than peach some landfill
pen we know that now and so that's why
we are benefiting from the World Cup
because we know Brazil better now and of
course Mario really the question of
course is that Brazil did not only apply
for the world cup but also the Olympics
Rio did only two years afterwards do you
think Brazil here bit off more than it
could chew well let's say that way that
it obviously template has the financial
power to pay but it has to to to change
its preferences what the where the money
goes so obviously there is a lack of
money and in other spendings and that's
what people are criticizing think that
we have to look at the politics of
Brazil year in the last ten years it
hasn't been really like a real
commendation of text money for example
digital no progressive tax law because
the right wing right wing parties that
are together with the government are
against it so what happened is the
redistribution of money was mainly
because of higher income that Brazil had
during the last year's this grows when
the growth went down this year and we're
so they had the the Olympics and the
soccer the football championship is a
gift to the big the big entrepreneurs in
Brazil I mean we know construction is
one of the windows of Brazilian economy
spreading all over the continent there
is Brazilian construction companies all
over the continent any huge project so
for them it's it's it's a winning game
and that what the concession of the
government to the rich and huge
entrepreneurs in Brazil that ninety
percent of it has to be paid by the
government is what people criticize and
I think that's the model that will not
be working anymore in the future to give
everything to the huge entrepreneurs and
hoping that there is a little bit of
trickle-down as soon as the merchants of
gross go down there is no trickle down
at all anymore and the government has
also not anymore the government that the
money to spend to at least pacify or
yeah the people and of course Brazil is
no exception when it comes to protest
ahead of a big sporting event in fact it
seems to be rather common these days
that a big sporting event is being
accompanied by a huge anti-government
protests and we will look at a few
examples here the 2014 sochi winter
olympics drew criticism for a number of
reasons among them the huge cost they
were the most expensive olympics ever
though the games themselves were
considered a success many question
whether the people of the region will
see the benefit in the long term
in Qatar which is due to host the 2022
soccer world cup concerns have focused
on the treatment of migrant workers
employed to build the stadiums there
have been many fatal accidents and some
workers have been forced to live in
unacceptable conditions and deny the
right to return to their home countries
in Brazil hundreds of landless families
have occupied an area near sau paulo
stadium where the opening match will be
held they aim to raise awareness that
far more is being spent on the World Cup
than on housing for the poor should FIFA
take more responsibility for them well a
state sochi Qatar and now Brazil it
seems that no sporting event can do
without huge protests prior prior to the
games being being staged yeah definitely
what we talked about the reasons because
people are kind of disillusioned with
her I think it's interesting to see in
Brazil he as already as he mentioned in
the last 10 years a lot of people were
freed from poverty with social welfare
programs by the by the government from
the Workers Party PT but then people had
more money but then they started
realizing that it's very expensive to
pay for a private school since they
didn't want to send the children anymore
to the public school which was bad and
then they realized it's it's it's
expensive to pay our private medicine
plan because they the public hospitals
are not working anymore and suddenly
they realize that if you have more money
that doesn't mean that you have more
civil rights and since there were
conscious about that and that's why the
Inga came from I think this could be one
explanation and then if they see if
there is money to choose to stage a
world cup and then they started
discussing the the kind of disparate
distribution even and they were
dissolute it because first the
government said ok it's mainly private
investment and then it turned out to be
mostly public investment so they were
kind of several
kind of disillusions that not just the
anger of the people it's when if you
look at the examples like Saatchi and
qatar and all the noise that is being
surrounded with these games it's still
worth it for a country to apply to stage
and host these games probably not just
just look what kind of country supplied
for the next World Cups it's Russia and
it's Qatar and I think there will be no
big movement against the world cup in
russia because we know the political
situation in Russia and there would be
no big movement and katara and we didn't
have a big movement in South Africa
either the thing is we're gonna have and
we already have a big movement social
movement again two against the world cup
in brazil we see in that last year when
we when we watch the other Confederation
Cup and it's going to be much bigger
this year because the world cup is such
a big stage with so many camera so many
people watching all over world and those
people were protesting against what
happens in brother would be stupid if
they didn't use this stage they're gonna
use this stage and there will be
protests we're gonna see in how far
they're gonna be literature don't you
think that it will be as always that
they'll be huge protests ahead of the
games and once the game starts the
excitement will take over I don't think
so it just take the example saatchi
saatchi was we were talking about
protest against Sochi it was mainly in
Europe and America not so much in Russia
and not in Sochi but they are big
protest in Brazil and that's the big
difference daria would you agree
definitely definitely also because we
can say that the social movements used
to be very strong in Brazil they've been
let's say demobilized in the last ten
years during the lula government and the
first result government but now they
restart mobilization that's what we saw
that did we saw so that that the first
mobilizations last year led to a series
of mobilizations in different sectors
that had and conformity and in
conformity and demands for a long time
but didn't find a way to mobilize they
found it they found out the courage to
mobilize the front the waist to mobilize
and even the
really harsh laws that are planned now
to introduce a terrorism law where
demonstrations can be called terrorism
and end up to 15 to 30 years in jail
won't stop that I think that the
protests will be growing 400,000 people
have been displaced from poor
neighborhoods in cities because they
were too close to the streets to the
stadium or whatever I think we will see
huge progress in there a lot of
possibilities police won't be able to
stop that I mean people can block
streets for example that I mean they're
all over roads that go to the stadium's
etc don't have to be in front of the
stadium they can block a row 10
kilometres ago and like and they have
the experience in Brazil it's not that
they don't have it so I think we're
going to see growing protests during and
after a state if that is true if the
thesis that the protest will continue
during the games as well it raises a
number of security issues doesn't it
Brazil will displace hundred seventy
thousand police officers spread out over
the 12th hosting cities and they are
already trying to control the favelas
which is not going so well is it well
there are positive and negative points
you maybe I can start with a positive
forint when they started in they started
this program it's called upp this is
kind of a piece unit police they started
it in 2008 in Rio de Janeiro and when
they first occupied the poor
neighborhood is it called favela there
was no no shirts no nothing you know
everything went peacefully and in the
first two years it was considered to be
a model people from all over the world
came there to see how brazil's managing
to to make a point against traffic
trafficking and crime and but then sure
you have they realized that the new
police is is the old police and they
brought the whole problems with them you
know violence ability everything which
which was associated with brazilian
police
but if you go to the neighborhoods and
ask the people most of them are still
saying that they live better than before
because if you went too far Veila before
there was the schools or kindergarten
well it was not working because the
teachers were not able to go to work
because of security issues people could
not visit each other because they were
living in one area dominated for one
fraction of crimes and they could not
leave it and go to the other area the
garbage was not collected services
didn't work so people say okay we have a
better life now it's it's better and
it's clear that there's a lot of
problems that innocent people have been
shot like there was a big example of
morula the police said they he was lost
or gone and then they had you know there
was big process and so on with public
pressure and they realized that they
that he was tortured so there is
problems it's not we cannot ignore it
but if you compare it before and talk to
the people they definitely will say no
we don't want to go back when do you
think security will be an issue
definitely definitely I seen the
Confederation Cup last year the game in
Rio de Janeiro Spain against Tahiti and
there were huge protests around the game
and after the game the Spanish coach was
asked did you see anything and he's
normally players or coaches they are we
just talking about sports forget it he
said yes we took the bus following the
Atlantica to to the Maracana stadium and
we seen strange things he said that was
that was strange never seen it before
and even that indicated to the
protestors proud protesters what kind of
stage they have and it's just a small
move from protest to violence and who's
going to control that the protesters
won't control that police I think can't
control it and uh I'm afraid violence
will be an issue the Brazilian called
Scolari is
that while he understands the grievances
on the part of the Brazilians he wishes
that or rather he criticizes the timing
of these protests he's saying you know
to protest is fine but now is not really
the time now is the time for Brazilians
to rally behind the team would he make
of a statement protested when when when
there's no camera that's no protest your
way you just protest if you got the
stage the World Cup is the stage and you
can't say hey protease is ok but behind
the stage that doesn't work that's not
in in the sense of protest that's stupid
and he knows that ya know it's a it's
obviously an absurd situation I mean if
we say is secure a problem with violence
is already there I mean police is
reported to be killing more and more use
and kids in the in the favelas now to
get just rid of them and I mean that's
the old way that they used to do it
before and apparently it stepped up
again the security issue I would say we
have a democracy problem because protest
is a democratic right and it's not
guaranteed anymore already now police is
cracking down on protests violent lee is
its resting journalists and protesters
is impeding any kind of protest so i
would say that if we look at the
Constitution democracy should be it
should be a higher have a higher value
than absolute security or let's say
because securing this case means to have
a sports game without any protests and
that's what people forget one way they
talk about security that we have a
democracy problem not a security problem
and a state of course a lot of is at
stake for the coach Scolari another
person for whom a lot is at stake is of
course Brazilian President Dilma
Rousseff she wanted these games and she
is up for re-election in October what do
you make of these what do you make of
her chances to get a second bit in light
of the protest that we're seeing right
now I think she she will be reelected
because it's not so because of her
merits but mostly because her a week
um adversaries because the two
candidates which are running for
president presidency also they are they
don't have and in the queries they don't
have that potential that she has and
that's why she probably will win I guess
and met let me just mention before from
the protest and it was interesting right
after the world's the Confed Cup last
year we had this world youth in meeting
from the Catholic and there were much
three million people in Rio de Janeiro
not in the whole Brazil like in only in
the city of Virginia from all over the
world from African countries Asia
Germany and it was interesting that the
same phrase was being repeated that this
is not the time for protests because
there was the fear that the protest
could spread around and continued during
the meeting and it was really incredible
to see that drew the protests we are
almost gone during this it was for 10
year 10 days for this 10 days 3 million
people were together at the Copacabana
beach and it was really crowded in the
night people slept there and it was
everything was calm and it was
incredible to see that that's how the
climate how the atmosphere changed and
maybe the Pope is contributing to a more
peaceful atmosphere than the football or
the FIFA I don't know but then you could
see there was a sudden sudden shift just
some days before there was still protest
like more violent protests and then
suddenly there was kind of a shift and
everybody was a surprised that things
went so smooth so of course these
protests aren't these are not the right
time since kalari these are not the
right time says Bruce off but aren't
these protests perhaps adding to a more
as spin were suggesting to a more
realistic international perception and
view of Brazil so far we are mostly
associating the country with
football with beach with good-natured
individuals and forgetting about for
perhaps a huge social inequality
inequalities that are existing in the
country yes definitely I mean it
contributes a dead but it's also wake-up
call not only on an international level
but also inside the country because
during the last ten years many people
expected you know everything is getting
better and like with little reforms we
can get out of and be like in the First
Nations club and etc and in that without
harming anyone without humming they did
the business men and without harming the
poor but obviously it did not work and
what's up will I very sure about it she
will win the elections but because there
is no alternative because any
alternative is even worse people don't
want an eternity on the right wing on
the conservative side that would be the
alternative to resolve in the elections
but they want the government to move
more to the left to make more
distributive politics to invest more
into the social sector to introduce
progressive taxes to text of the
employees to make more laws about
business investments that's what people
want and that's what has been up to now
in a period by the right wing government
partners of Rousseff we have to see that
that the presidential election is about
the president but the PT does not have a
majority to build an own government and
that has been also a break on severe
changes in Brazil during last year's and
spent for many years Brazil has been
considered to be one of the big emerging
powers it was almost seen as inevitable
that Brazil will be in the top four or
five of Nations as far as might and
economic power is concerned now the
Brazilian economy is in a bit of a slump
we see high inflation we see corruption
mismanagement do you think that the
Brazil's rise to the top perhaps is
turning out not so inevitable after all
I'm not sure we had these problems or
Brazil have these problems before we can
see them more clearly now that's the
difference and it's a long way from
from a kind of kind of third world
country to one of the big nations Brazil
has the capacity definitely by the test
to do a lot of work until it so it's on
the top and I don't think how long it's
going to take you maybe you got better
figures but I think we won't see that in
the next 10 or 15 years and I don't
think so I said where is Brazil heading
well I think Brazil is heading forward
even though it's not a Chinese at a
china which dick has like growing rates
from from seven or eight percent last
year it was 2.5 and this year maybe only
one or 1.5 but i agree i think to
understand brazil it's very important to
to see how the archer political
architecture is working and all the
Presidents had to have to make a
compromise compromise with the Congress
and that's why we don't have this tax
reform which is owned already for 20 or
25 years or people are waiting for it
because this there's a lobby and there
are interest fights and that's things
are moving slowly I mean if you look
twenty thirty years ago Brazil has
tremendously changed we in the European
Union we took even more time so we have
to think we have to be a little bit more
patient and consider the progress that
has been reached already and give Brazil
amor more time because we have to look
on our own history we need at that same
time but that's [ __ ] I mean it's that's
clear that there you have heavy interest
conflict even in a country like with a
history like Brazil so that's something
very natural and I think the the world
cup is is like a flash point you see its
use you know everybody's using the cup
the world cup that's for for his own
purpose and then things show up became
more clearly and and and more urgent
that's I think the World Cup has this
capacity to bring things forward
to see it in a positive way because you
mentioned China at least Brazil is a
democracy maybe not the best in the
world but it is a democracy Russia is
not what we call perfect democracy and
China is not even close becoming a
democracy wait what happens if China
ever becomes a democracy if there's a
working population demanding its rights
wait wait and see what happens then well
first of all China needs to work on
building up a better football team
that's for certain because they will not
compete in the world cup but daddy let's
get back once more to Brazil in a sense
in association and relations with these
with this world cup following scenario
brazil wins the World Cup on final day
these protests will go away no I don't
think they will go away I mean people
will be happy obviously people will be
partying a few days and a few nights
probably but the protests won't be going
away people will be even asking more
because they will ask okay we got the
title what else do we got it's this
title really worth 14 billion dollars i
mean people this products don't go away
these it's a breaking point for
Brazilian politics the elections are
very close now so there's we won't
expect a change of politics or
announcement before the elections but
after the elections i think if nothing
changes it there might be bigger
fractions inside the government party or
in other areas the protests will step up
probably the movements won't be quiet
anymore towards the PT government it
might shake the country I think it will
shake the country a lot and so that's
what I would expect after even after a
victory it's fine let's talk briefly
about the players about the Brazilian
players because they a little bit in a
dilemma aren't they because they have
expressed sympathy for the protesters
because many of them are coming from
rather disadvantaged economic
backgrounds themselves yet at the same
time they need to focus
on the task of getting Brazil it's a
sick world cup so it's a bit of a
dilemma here it is and they definitely
been told by the Association just to to
shut up and don't talk about these
issues and the thing is they are coming
from the favelas but football nowadays
especially a professional football in
brazil isn't isn't the word until of
sports anymore just to just look at the
stadium's look who's going to do
maracana stadium when fluminense up
place there are no more guys coming from
the favelas because they can't afford
the tickets when I've seen the NSC when
I seen the games at the Confederation
Cup the crowd there there were no
working people it wasn't middle class
and has a great shift going on these
days and i'm not sure where we're going
to go with this well we're going to go
with this we will of course continue to
follow ashley but if you would put on
your future glasses ahead of the games
what happens afterwards the protest will
continue says Dario and then what the
Pandora's box has been open to what
extent well I think it depends on the
result if the result is positive I think
the real action for Dilma would be
smooth and easy and if not I mean she
will have to to face some some more
protests I guess and unrest and
discontentment and I think after the
election there will be the bill
presented for the Brazilian population
because their taxes might rise and the
additional cost may may result in in
more public death and this all will be
have a big influence in economic outlook
of the of a country but it depends also
on ok she Duma has still more four years
then and depends on which team she will
coordinate so I think it depends on
really on the election rate and
although on the world she will get and
on the team she will building and I
think Brazil will have to pay the bill
after the elections but let's def will
be after the election after the World
Cup but let's focus on the world cup for
the remainder of our time because this
is despite the clashes and the protest
this is after all a sporting events
who's going to take it germany germany
is set to be frontrunner we are here we
are here at deutsche welle of course so
we have to root for germany and and
they're saying this could be the first
european team ever to win the World Cup
on South American soil what's your take
I don't think so i think it's going to
be a south american team Brazil's got
excellent chances but just among us it's
gonna be a boy or ago I well there's a
very oracle very arrogant well oreg why
of course want won it before on
Brazilian soil in the Maracana so you're
expecting a repeat here I hope so Dario
what's your take do you think Brazil
Brazil is gonna fulfill the hopes of
millions of Brazilians I sincerely don't
think so I mean people often say that
the performance of the soccer team
corresponds usually do the performance
of the countries like politically
economically etc so i would think that
since Brazil isn't some kind of stall
situation if we could transfer that to
the team then I think they won't win but
I share I don't know if ye will would be
nice i hope it for or why but i think it
will not be a european team and it will
not be preserved what would is sick the
World Cup title mean for Brazil do you
think it has the potential to even serve
as a glue to bring society together
again well for for a few days yes but
like carnival does it for a few days in
Brazil but then people recognize again
that it takes them two hours and they
have to spend half of their salary to
get take the bus to go to work or that
they don't have decent schools for their
children or that they fin
university studies and the universities
but then they don't get a well-paid job
in the private industry so it will last
a few days but I don't think that it
will last longer than that also do you
think even if Brazil were to win the
effect would only last a few days and
then it will evaporate no I think if
Brazil when it's it's something very
historic because it's like well I
remember when I ate onsen or died 20
years ago people were asking why
Brazilians are so concerned about a car
running so and then the answer is they
like winners and the more wrong the
country goes of more problems they have
the more important is that they win the
World Cup so that that the workup would
show that they are number one in the
international community with at least
football and there are number one with
other things but this is something that
nobody can really discuss so I think
it's very important even if the problems
are growing it's more important for
brazil to win because it's a kit and
it's a question of national pride and
this is very important well spend before
we run out of time you saying Germany
won't win it let's give us a gilded
glimmer of hope at least how far will
Germany go I think they're going to make
it to the semi-final but even that's
going to be hard to take at all i got a
quite smooth pre group and they if they
make it first in their group they are
going to make it to to the quarter-final
and they've got
they've gotta make to sing I see well we
will say we will of course continue to
follow both the protest but as of course
also the matches which at least I'm very
much looking forward to I want to thank
my guests for a very spirited discussion
on the current economic political
situation in Brazil thank you for tuning
in and looking forward to seeing you
again next week for a new edition of cod
Riga
you